it's great to be joined today by Marc
Sageman who's a former CIA operations
officer who covered as a foreign service
officer and was based in Afghanistan
from 1987 to 1989 Marc it's so great to
speak to you and I'm interested in
speaking to you about the sort of
epistemology of terrorism the sources of
radicalization there's so much there's
so many attempts made to sort of point
to how radicalization happens and I want
to start breaking it down with you a
little bit if we can so first tell us
just a bit about your experience dealing
with terrorism around the world is your
in your role with the CIA well I can't
say too much about my role at the CIA
however I can say that I was in direct
contact with what we call the Mujahideen
bang which we viewed as freedom fighters
now this some of the same people are
fighting against the Kabul regime and we
call them terrorists so you can see here
that the problem is one of definition
and it depends where you stand if they
are on our side we call them freedom
fighters and if they're on the other
side we call them terrorists my dealing
with them is that they were just like
soldiers fighting invaders namely the
Soviets at the time and I didn't really
think much of it I mean they were just
like the type of sailors that I used to
deal with when I was in the Navy the US
Navy and is that mark is that a common
would you say in general within the CIA
that there is this sort of a moral view
of these sometimes called terrorists the
idea that we may not agree with the side
or the movement that they're fighting
for but that operationally fundamentally
they're not really different than a
of the American military would you say
that's a widespread view in the CIA well
if they on our side we tend to accept
them and we tend to accept them as
either freedom fighters or Oh soldiers
just like s talk a little bit about
radicalization in the United States in
sort of layman's terms or popular
discussions we often like to say well
what we need to look at is religion as
the source of radicalization for
terrorists or we need to look at how our
or other foreign policy has impacted
individuals to understand the
radicalization or other factors can you
shed a little bit of light on that in
terms of what you believe works towards
the radicalization of individuals the
term radicalization just like the term
terrorists is very confusing and perhaps
we should get rid of it
radicalization means two things which
are not the same and indeed quite
different one is the acquisition of
radical ideas namely ideas that reject
what people in domains to him think and
the other is the turning to political
violence and the two are quite different
you can be politically violent but still
have mainstream ideas and you can have
radical ideas and be extremely
nonviolent such as Gandhi for instance
yeah so for our discussion just that's a
good point and just to be clear I'm
thinking more of the political violence
side of it right and that's what most
people are interested but the problem is
that they confuse the two and just as
you point out one view of it is that
they have a radical ideology that leads
them to become violent and that is
because of the confusion of the two
senses of the term the two are not
equivalent and so when you want to look
at radicalization
returning to political violence you
really need to focus on that what is the
role of ideology Fenny and how what is a
process by which people become violent
and I basically broke it down in five
processes by looking at political
violence throughout history going back
to the French Revolution so this allows
us to see what's common to all the
people who became politically violent in
during domestic peace time not during
war because we're in war basically is
very trivial to think about how people
become violent it just joined the army
and their soldiers for their country but
what about peacetime well what we see is
that people for some grievances become
acquire a political social identity and
the collection of people acquiring this
identity is a political protest
community and the political protest
community we have you know thousands of
them and most and most of them are
nonviolent for them to become violent
you need basically three types of
condition one is an escalation of
conflict between this community and the
state the second condition is people get
disillusioned with nonviolent protest
and the third condition is moral outrage
against an egregious aggression of the
state against a community under the
three condition a few people within the
community volunteer to protect their
community and become violent against
both the state and society now when you
solve a state mark does it have to does
it have to be the state that the
individuals are in because it seems
sometimes the political violence is
catalyzed maybe
by sentiment against some other state
that's not the one that the individuals
were talking about actually reside in
that is correct it's basically a
question of identification you identify
with a community that's being either
persecuted or being killed and you know
for instance honor kists in the nineties
late 19th century felt very strongly
when other anarchists were being killed
by other states like Italy or France and
we have actually a lot of Americans who
went back to Europe to to the for
instance kill an Italian King or so it
really depends on who do you identify
with and this becomes an imagined
political protest community so for
instance because the Assad regime lately
was killing Sunni Muslims a lot of Sunni
Muslims around the world identified with
the victims and one end to fight against
the Assad regime over the years they
were basically incorporated in what we
call the Islamic state because they were
probably the most efficient fighting
force against the Assad regime
now when the West started intervening in
2014 a lot of those foreign fighters
turned against the West because now the
West became an enemy so it's a little
bit more complicated it's not always
against your own state would be against
another state but if your own state then
engages in the fight as an enemy then of
course your own state becomes an enemy
well there's sometimes this dichotomy in
the United States where there are some
who like to argue that the roots of at
least the current what we call Islamic
terrorism that the roots are inherently
the teachings of Islam
and there are others who like to say
were it not for American or Western
foreign policy you wouldn't see many of
these individuals become perpetrators of
political violence it sort of sounds
like what you're suggesting and correct
me if I'm wrong is that you can have
foreign policy create circumstances in
which religion or another factor can
create that outrage that you called part
three of the radicalization process am i
sort of understanding you correctly yes
that is correct it's not so much as a
religion create a moral outrage is that
you identify with people who share the
same religion as you do and when those
people are being killed abroad you
become morally outraged and if your
state is the one killing them through
bombings then you decide you you kill my
guys there I'll kill your guys here your
work talks a lot about the roots of sort
of modern political violence of the type
that we're talking about you talk a lot
about the role of Egypt can you talk a
little bit about that for our audience
who may not be familiar with that part
of the history well in this wave of
political violence and again my last
book turning to political violence goes
back to the French Revolution and
demonstrated at the same processes have
been going on in the 18th century in
19th century and 20th century and in
fact Islam has is very late in terms of
Islamism I should say is very late in
terms of political ideology here that
may inspire some people to become
violent
in this last wave namely this what I
call the global neo jihad Egypt as they
played a very important role because it
in a sense developed the rationale that
we need to
we bail against really our own states
before we we bail against the foreign
state that prop up our own state there
was the second stage in that that that
came from Afghanistan where some people
went to Afghanistan to protect and to
defend their own community against
Soviet invasion that was when I was
there at the time and they started to
look at why don't we go after what's
called the far enemy as opposed to the
near enemy out on state the far enemy
other people who Pro topo on state and
you start seeing a shift in the 1990s
where some of those neo jihadi attack
the West you know one of them was a
first World Trade Center bombing and
then our Embassy bombing in East Africa
and and 9/11 and so he can see the
escalation yeah let's pause our
conversation right there we're speaking
with Marc Sageman former CIA operations
officer we will continue with him on
tomorrow's program we're continuing our
conversation with Marc Sageman who's a
former CIA operations officer he covered
as a foreign service officer was based
in Afghanistan from 1987 to 1989 Marc in
the first part of the conversation we
talked a lot about the origins and
sources of both the of both terrorism as
it is sometimes defined and of
radicalization as you defined it for us
in the first part of the interview let's
start now
with dealing with this from the point of
view of country's foreign policy what do
you see is the biggest failures
particularly from Western nations in
dealing with what you describe as Neo
jihadi terror well one of the important
aspect is really propping up tyrannies
in the Middle East that's what gave the
West a bad name in the Middle East
bring up Mubarak now [ __ ] propping up
the Saudi government being friends with
Assad for a while and now what we have
is that we have direct intervention in
both Syria and Iraq and we've seen as a
combatant and a legitimate target of
violence so can you explain that a
little more because when I hear you say
I mean I understand the problems of
course of propping up dictatorships not
only in the Middle East we've seen it in
Latin America we've seen it elsewhere
how does that foreign policy decision
from the u.s. lead to the for example
radicalization of individuals into Isis
what's the path there well the best is
usually humanitarian you you know a lot
of them see videos it's not really the
videos of decapitation which are really
directing not at their own followers but
they really sensational videos directed
at the West but it's really videos of
young children being killed being killed
by sarin gas being killed by barrel
bombs and so a lot of those people in
the West and they've been thousand
especially from France and
french-speaking countries deciding to go
to Syria and say you know enough is
enough I can't really stand by and I
need to to protect those people
especially since you know there's not
much for me to do at home
and so the way of going to Syria was not
from the United States it was really
from a lot of those excluded members of
French society as they call them in
front of these excluded and so they
weren't there and then when we started
becoming involved in in the bombings
there not only do soldiers in Syria the
Mujahideen in Syria as they think of
themselves not only did they go after
the West
especially France because France was one
of the major major proponent to
involvement in Syria but also the United
States and so as we bomb people in Syria
as we bomb Isis in Syria there are some
sympathizers of Isis here in this
country who identify with the people
being killed and and decide to get
involved and so they feel that if we
bomb them there
well they'll bomb is here and that's
basically I think what happened in San
Bernardino in Orlando in this country
and Mark once someone let's let's go to
step two right whatever the initial
movement or the initial forces are or
moves that push people to radicalization
and to becoming aligned or affiliated
with something like Isis does the do the
individual political reasons matter
anymore or is it community is it
something else that keeps individuals
involved it's both I mean one is a sense
of moral outrage and taking individual
responsibility to defend one's community
but of course it's supported and
reinforced by constant talk on the
Internet or via Twitter's of all of
Facebook pages through social media so
that very much reinforce you know the
volunteers what we call terrorists to
carry out their actions now there will
be people who hear us talking about this
and they'll say David hold on a second
or Mark hold on a second usually it's me
that they criticize they'll say why why
wouldn't a belief for example that there
will be 72 virgins awaiting someone in
heaven if they commit a suicide bombing
why aren't you talking more about that
because that creates a very particular
impetus for participating or not in an
individual politically violent act how
do we parse that how do we evaluate
those particular beliefs and the role
that
my play well first of all you can see
that sex has never been a very strong
factor in political violence and the
people who asked that question I usually
ask the same question to them well would
you kill yourself for 72 virgins in
heaven and most of them start laughing
and I laugh with them because say well
that's exactly the same response that
you know the terrorists okay
for maybe the 72 virgins example
specifically is the wrong one but the
idea of an eternity somewhere where the
God you believe in is very happy with
the act of political violence you
committed on earth maybe is a broader
example well you see as Westerners we
basically identify with Westerners as
victims of this terrorist and we have a
tendency to look at members of an out
group in terms of stereotyped
one-dimensional person we reduce them to
really nonsense and it's a reflection of
our prejudice and so when we think that
they are responsive to such motivation
that we know us ourselves will not
respond to this is basically what
prejudice is all about in fact they
don't do it because of that you know
I've interviewed at least 30 convicted
terrorists because of my legal work I'm
usually the expert witness in a lot of
this tribal trials you know I
interviewed them in Afghanistan in this
country in Saudi Arabia and believe me
it was not for the 72 virgins
what can countries like the United
States do that you believe would have
the effect of reducing the propensity to
this type of radicalization well there
are several things one is not to
stigmatize that community not really may
King Muslims different from the rest of
us American and unfortunately that's
exactly what the government is doing
right now because many Muslims feel that
they are being harassed if not
persecuted in terms of you know the way
they have to act differently or the way
the government acts towards them at
airports and so on so what we need to do
is to explain to Muslim that you know
the United States is made of many
communities but we all want we all
American and we cannot distinguish
between them and stigmatize them we also
have to do a much better job explaining
our foreign policy especially to
communities that are directly involve by
those policies and which we should
really try to bring those people who are
very much hostile to the United States
within the United States back into the
fold you know this needs to two leaders
political leaders need to show
leadership and try to create a sense of
identity we all Americans and not just
now stigmatize people and say our
Muslims really are not Americans or they
have to show their loyalty this is not
doing this type of stigmatization is
probably the worst thing it's probably
the first step that leads to political
violence the new book is turning to
political violence we've been speaking
with the book's author Marc Sageman
who's a former CIA operations officer
Marc very interesting and I really
appreciate you talking to me about it
well thank you it's my pleasure